a middle-class Caracas neighborhood was
the scene of opposition leader Huang
widows first rally this year if there
are gates fences or walls to jump we
will jump them and if we cannot jump
over them we will knock them down on
Tuesday the majority opposition faction
that he leads forced his way into
Parliament to stays after why though was
prevented by soldiers from entering the
legislature the government is now
recognizing another deputy a Speaker of
the House why Dahl says he won't meet
with a Norwegian delegation that's
reportedly in Caracas to attempt to
restart negotiations that broke down
last year between the government and
opponents he says there are no
conditions for dialogue but while the
news whale as political and economic
crisis worsens it's clear that the
opposition has lost momentum people
mobilized in support of why though 12
months later either out of fear
frustration or the belief that the
opposition simply doesn't have what it
takes to unseat the military-backed
government why go has only been able to
bring out a few hundred people here
nevertheless he pleaded for Venezuelans
not to abandon him today more than ever
we need to all fight together to open
the door to freedom because I confess to
you we cannot do it alone
whether Venezuelans will heed his call
and accompany him next week in a new
attempt to enter parliament remains to
be seen Lucia Neumann al Jazeera Caracas